17 واعتقلنا بسبب احتجاجنا على حرماننا من
النوم ، عذبنا ولعننا في
الاعتراف بشيء لم أفعله.
بدعوى تعرضه لسوء المعاملة في الحجز ، فإن
الاعتراف كتبه
المحقق ، ولم أوقعه إلا بعد
التعذيب والتهديد ، وهذه تصريحات
أدلى بها في محكمة سعودية بعض من
37 شخصًا نُفذت أحكامهم بالإعدام
في ثاني أكبر عملية إعدام جماعي
في المملكة مؤخرًا.  التاريخ
طه والحج تطاردهم
قصصهم ، فقد كان محامياً في
وطنه السابق في المملكة العربية السعودية حيث
مثل لفترة وجيزة بعض من
أعدموا في أبريل / نيسان فيما وصفه بتهم
ملفقة وجاسوسة
وإرهاب يوم
إعدامهم السعودي.  قالت الحكومة
إنه تم تحقيق العدالة ،
لكن مئات الصفحات من
الوثائق التي حصلت عليها سي إن إن
حصريًا تكشف عن رواية أخرى
وثقتها المحكمة  هذا دليل على التعذيب
والظلم ولا يزال لديهم
الجرأة ليقولوا إنهم رحماء
وإنسانية ويقول المتهمون إنهم
اعترفوا لأنهم
تعرضوا للتعذيب الذي كان ينبغي
التحقيق فيه بموجب القانون السعودي في
وقت مبكر ، ومن المفترض أن يأخذ القاضي الأمر على
محمل الجد.  اطلب من
المحققين إجابة على هذه
المزاعم ولكن ما يحدث في معظم
هذه القضايا هو أن القاضي يتجاهل ذلك.
نفت المملكة العربية السعودية اتهامات
التعذيب في الماضي
ولم ترد الحكومة السعودية على
استفسارات CNN العديدة حول
مزاعم الاعتراف بموجب القانون.  التعذيب كما ورد
في المحكمة
يتهم البشر من بين الجرائم بارتكاب
أعمال عنف تجسس
تنظيم مظاهرات
وتصوير مقاطع فيديو مضللة والتواصل مع
وسائل الإعلام الأجنبية
يشتبه طه في أن الحكومة
ربما اتهمته بارتكاب جرائم كاذبة
أثناء تواجده في السعودية.
طلب منه المثول في مركز للشرطة
هرب من نفس المكان  يومًا ولكن حتى هنا في
اللغة الألمانية ، فهو حذر من
مخالب الحكومة السعودية بعيدة المدى ، إنها
رسالة بأدب شديد من
السفارة السعودية هنا أنه اكتشف على
هاتفه كيف حصلوا على رقمك عليه
وفتحوا تعديلًا للجمهور  لا أعرف
كيف حصلوا على رقمي ، لقد
كان هذا رقمًا جديدًا ، الرسالة من
شخص يدعي أنه مسؤول سعودي
في برلين تقول إن الوطن لا يزال
يرحب بأبنائه بأذرع مفتوحة ، وإذا
كنت ترغب في ذلك ، يمكنني مساعدتك في العودة ، فأنا
أضمن لك  عودة سهلة
ستشكرني على أن شبكة سي إن إن حصلت على
فيديو جديد حصري في التحقيق في مقتل
كاتب العمود في صحيفة واشنطن بوست جمال بعد بضعة أشهر.
في وقت مبكر من الصباح
، فكرت في جيب أنني يمكن أن أكون في
نفس حالة جمال إذا وافقت
على أن هذا قد أفادني على الفور
، يقول إن حكومته يمكن أن تحاول الوصول
إليه حتى  هنا لكنه لن يتوقف عن
استخدام حريته ليكون صوتًا
لأولئك الذين ما زالوا في الداخل لأولئك الذين
يتعرضون للتعذيب والإساءة لأولئك
الذين لا يستطيعون الصراخ حتى وهم في حالة
ألم.
Arwa Damon CNN Berlin